well this is the al tahira church in
western
mosul and as you can see it is
completely destroyed one of so many
buildings right across this city
that was destroyed as the iraqi
government army moved in to try and push
the islamic state out the islamic state
had been in control of this city indeed
it was their capital city
for four years between 2014 and 2017
it was the heart of their caliphate and
you can see some of the desecration here
uh locals tell us that the tombs where
christians were buried inside the church
were opened up and they themselves were
desecrated as well it is quite
remarkable that the pope has not only
come
to this country but to this city as well
and we'll be here at this church he will
be
just outside as you can see there um
just putting the finishing touches on
uh the area where he will hold prayers
where he will say a few words and all
around behind you can make out
the devastation it is total uh
devastation in this part
of mosul the final battle to remove the
islamic state went on for
many many days and it was very difficult
a very difficult battle
for the iraqi forces eventually they did
win but remnants of the islamic state do
still
endure we were hearing yesterday of the
potential of sleeper cells here
in iraq clearly in syria as well there
is a
an islamic state stronghold there so so
the final
fight to to rid this part of the world
of the extremism of the islamic state
endures and i think that is
at the heart of one of the pope's many
messages as he comes here he has been
talking about
interfaith tolerance and about the
removal
of extremism his meeting today with
grand ayatollah ali al-sistani
the most revered shia muslim cleric here
in iraq and indeed a man
whose teachings are listened to right
around the muslim world that was a
very very symbolic moment you can see up
there
the poster one of many across this part
of the country uh
which will welcome him as he comes here
to mosul tomorrow as i say
quite extraordinary it was only um a few
weeks ago that people were suggesting
that this trope this trip may not happen
because of the security situation
there are questions about whether it's
sensible with coronavirus
as well but the pope was determined that
he would come
he was determined that he would reflect
his teaching
of interfaith tolerance that he's been
talking about so much here
over the past couple of days
you